[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro de dimanche en politique très
heureux de vous retrouver en ce dimanche
matin en direct
lrm lrp srn divers gauche ou encore
divers droite le gouvernement voulait
supprimer les étiquettes politiques pour
les communes de moins de 9000 habitants
cette disposition présentée dans une
circulaire du ministre de l'intérieur
christophe castaner a été retoqué par le
conseil d'état le seul sera finalement
fixé à 3500 habitants pour l'opposition
la majorité veut minimiser une
éventuelle défaite électorale aux
municipales en focalisant les résultats
sur les grandes villes censé lui être
plus favorables alors ces étiquettes
politiques ont-elles encore un sens dans
les petites communes que distel notre
débat démocratique au moment où beaucoup
de candidats décident de ne plus
afficher le logo de leur parti cette
polémique est elle encore justifié le
gouvernement
manoeuvre utile en coulisses pour
minimiser une possible défaite on en
débat ce matin avec nos invités jérôme
durain bonjour bonjour vous êtes
sénateur socialiste de saône et loire
sébastien mirek bonjour bonjour vous
êtes le référent de la république en
marche en côte d'or jean vigreux bonjour
nos joueuses être professeur d'histoire
à l'université de bourgogne franche
comté vous guidons regardez vous pouvez
bien sûr commenter cette émission en
direct sur les réseaux sociaux avec le
hashtag dean paul bourgogne alors jean
vigreux j'ai envie de m'adresser d'avoir
un historien ces étiquettes politiques à
lille ont toujours existé dans notre
histoire ah oui c'est quelque chose où
c'est sur le temps long ça s'inscrit
alors on pourrait le reprendre sous la
vème république parce que déjà
l'histoire est longue mais on peut le
reprendre dès 1848 les premières
élections municipales et la mise en
oeuvre en quelque sorte de valeurs
d'éthique est alors la protohistoire des
partis politiques c'est le début avec
aussi un suffrage qui n'est pas
universel il est semi universel pendant
très longtemps il ya que les hommes qui
vont voter les maires on va les nommés
pendant longtemps
n'oublions pas que c'est seulement à
partir de 1884 avec les lois ferry que
on à l'élection du maire alors dans un
deuxième temps après les élections des
listes municipales
mais les étiquettes sont présentes et
elles permettent aussi de penser
l'héritage de la révolution
française c'est vraiment à ce moment là
que connaît gauche et droite dans notre
imaginaire politique et pas simplement
dans notre imaginaire dans notre
pratique politique
la révolution elle invente quelque chose
de fondamental c'est que un plus un
égale 1 ont fait les communes en 1790 la
maison commune la mairie comme on l'a
derrière derrière vous et à partir de ce
moment là une commune plus une commune
ça fait un canton un canton plus un
canton ça fait un département est un
département plus un département ça fait
un état nation et ça nous permet de
comprendre la place des municipalités
dans notre modèle républicain
si à la fois la souveraineté nationale
et c'est en même temps leurs
représentants de l'état et de ce point
de vue là la synthèse qui est inventé
c'est spécifique à notre modèle
républicain et bien sûr joue sur le
temps long entre gauche et droite
alors oui il ya eu des moments où on a
eu des étiquettes et des moments on a
voulu les retirer dans les années 60
sous la vème république gaullienne
on essayait de les gommer
en 1959 par exemple le les gaullistes
pensée reprend toutes les villes aux
communistes puisqu'il avait gagné en 58
il échoue et à chaque moment on essaie
de voir donc on va inventer cette
éthique
parmi ces étiquettes vous groupe mais on
voit que ces tickets sont très liés
finalement municipal alors qu'on
pourrait penser que l'élection
municipale n'est pas une élection de
politique politicienne bien sûr il ya à
la fois des enjeux locaux et c'est
fondamental
et puis aussi des enjeux nationaux il ya
le contrecoup des élections nationales
les municipales alors on va revenir à la
cinquième république j'ai évoqué 1959
c'est l'échec gaullisme on pourra aller
plus loin 1977 sous giscard d'estaing
c'est la conquête des municipalités par
la gauche qui va emmener 1980 et puis
1981 victoire de la gauche et 83 des
fêtes et on pourrait le faire des
élections intermédiaires d'autant plus
depuis le 15 c'est un outil d'autant
plus depuis le catena et regardez par
exemple les municipales de 2001 où la
gauche a perdu beaucoup dans les
quartiers populaires etc des villes
populaires dans la région cette essence
qui était perdu
me semble-t-il a contrario ayant gagné
paris lyon et dijon ça à masquer
quelques décrochages forme de voilà il
ya toujours ce cet aller retour entre le
local et national
jérôme durand que les élections
municipales mérite des étiquettes
politiques selon vous oui elle mérite
des étiquettes politiques
on était avec les viticulteurs d'un
certain nombre de responsables publics
le devant linea haut pour réclamer la
défense du beaujolais l'appellation
d'origine contrôlée donc on veut savoir
ce qu'on boit on veut savoir ce qu'on
mange
les citoyens veulent savoir où sont
fabriqués les produits et en politique
final on s'intéressera plus aux idées
c'est quand même assez étrange et
paradoxal et il ya depuis 2010 est
notamment l'idée que la politique c'est
fini la fin de l'histoire avec fukuyama
92 et puis maintenant il ya la fin de la
politique ni droite ni gauche le en même
temps mais la politique c'est pas sale
c'est pas honteux car on a le droit dans
une élection municipale de ne pas avoir
d'option de ne pas avoir d' affiliation
partisane très bien mais on peut aussi
respecter ce qu'ils veulent dire
moi j'ai une sensibilité qui est elle le
problème avec sept circuits d'art
castaner c'est que on essaye de
barbouiller les carreaux un de masquer
la réalité
moi je pense que la politique le débat
d'idées il est moteur d'ailleurs la
constitution elle dit les partis
politiques et les groupements contribuer
à l'expression du suffrage
donc c'est sain de savoir pour qui on
vote ce qu'il pense s'il n'a pas envie
de se revendiquer de tel ou tel parti
très bien et est d'ailleurs les textes
avant la circulaire castaner le
permettait en revanche qu'on permette un
élu même dans une commune de 50
habitants même dans une commune de sont
habitants de dire moi je suis écologiste
moi je suis socialiste je suis comme ils
disent que ce n'est pas forcément la
même chose d'un point de vue des idées
sébastien mirek est ce que l'absence
d'étiquette la volonté finalement du
nouveau monde de dire vous ayez eu ni
droite ni gauche et droite et gauche
c'est la négation des idées politiques
alors je vais revenir sur ce point là en
fait l'élection municipale n'est pas une
élection d'étiquettes
c'est ce que effectivement ce qu on
pourrait évoquer mais une élection sans
étiquette ce n'est pas une élection qui
est sans idée sans idéologie est en fait
le sens de cette circulaire est le sens
de ce que souhaitent
d'un autre côté la république en marche
ses portes et progressistes municipal et
porter progressisme municipal c'est
faire le débat d'idées ça apporte une
idéologie
c'est aussi élargir son socle ce qu'on
souhaite aussi c'est un âge et notre
socle d'élus locaux de soutien la
majorité présidentielle quoi le progrès
c'est parce que pour moi le progressisme
municipal je voyais ça plutôt à gauche
alors quand on parle de progressisme en
général c'est plutôt à gauche or vos
élus ou vos futurs élus en tout cas vos
candidats sont sont souvent associés à
des à des anciens l air ou à des actuels
et l'air dans les différentes communes
on a le progress municipal c'est quoi un
bien c'est les travaux qu'on fait la
république en marche notamment le ski a
été sorti sur les meilleurs pour nos
communes 300 projets qui marchent donc
c'est 80 élus cadres du parti animateurs
locaux adhérents marcheurs députés qui
ont travaillé en fait pendant lui - pour
sortir 300 projets qui marchent avec des
projets alors j'en ai en tête notamment
dans la nièvre avec denis thuriau qui
est le maire de nevers et qui lui
finance le permis pour des jeunes qui
s'investissent dans les collectivités
donc on fait ce qu'on souhaite vous avez
pris les idées qui fonctionne dans des
communes d'ailleurs de différentes
sensibilités c'est ça bien sûr en fait
différentes sensibilités avec des
soutiens et avec des projets qui sont
portées on a aussi pour les soutiens et
les investitures fait signer une charte
de dix engagements des élus
progressistes sur la laïcité sur la
représentativité sur le renouvellement
des visages sur l'engagement envers les
générations futures
donc ça c'est des majors pas parce qu'il
n'ya pas d'étiquette qui a pas d'idée
absolument pas il ya des idées ya une
idéologie est ce qu'on souhaite c'est
les portes et continue à les porter et
dernièrement il est sorti à la fin du
mois de janvier qui a été validé par le
bureau exécutif dix recommandations sur
comment lutter contre le rassemblement
national dans les villes où il ya ces
difficultés la gironde du rabbin moi
j'ai rien compris et rêve d'abord je ne
comprends pas comment on peut porter le
progressisme municipal quant au niveau
national on porte la réalisation parce
que la réalité quand même c'est que on
peut pas dire nous au niveau local or on
va être progressiste et organiser une
action publique nationale qui est
régressive et d'ailleurs le fc eu cette
semaine vient de pointer que l'action
des manuels macron l epad ni droite ni
gauche
droite donc il ya des citoyens qui vont
vous dire mais pourquoi dans une
élection locale
vous introduisez ce débat national
jérôme durain qu'est-ce qui le
justifient selon vous ce que moi je veux
pas qu'on nous prenne pour des ânes et
qu'on dise aux électeurs des choses qui
ne sont pas vraies il ya un moment donné
à parti politique c'est fait pour
produire des idées
si toutes les idées sont bonnes à
prendre et bien ya plus d'idées il ya
plus de clivage est ce que vous faites
avec votre notre bouquin là votre
recueil de recommandation tout le monde
le fait tous les maires quelle que soit
leur sensibilité vont chercher les
bonnes pratiques
idéalement il est donc essayer de se
camoufler derrière des formules creuses
du type progressisme municipal ça ne
sert pas la démocratie
vous aimez plus socialiste s'y met enfin
moi je préfère dire je suis socialiste
que je suis un homme de gauche que je
suis je suis pour la redistribution que
je pense qu'il faut pas organiser nos
politiques fiscales qui re distributif
pour les riches et faire du robin des
bois à l'envers ça c'est des vérités et
c'est pas des formules un peu creusé
environ
ouais non mais l'étiquette progressistes
sur l'histoire parce que moi je la
regarde sur le temps on n'est pas
simplement dans le temps présent vous
aviez des sénateurs qui s'appelait
progressistes au moment du front
populaire et qui voter à droite
donc ça veut rien dire sur l'étiquette
ça c'est la l'idéologie à un moment
donné les pratiques politiques et les
reclassements politique qui font que
alors là ce qui était intéressant et
dans ce qui était dit on va prendre des
bonnes recettes un peu partout et on en
fait on en fait une soupe en quelque
sorte et on enfin un programme pour tout
le monde c'est très techniciste mais
derrière ce qui pourrait être
intéressant c'est de voir aussi et bien
sûr quelle valeur ça repose et là on
voit des sensibilités apparaître et
voire des contradictions c'est le en
même temps du contradictoire de ce point
de vue là qui peut qui peut arriver et
les landais à droite et à gauche
peut-être mais en même temps à force de
dire on dépolitise en faisant ça eh bien
on laisse émerger d'autres radicalité et
des radicalités qui propose propose de
renverser le système et ça peut être
qu'il y faut aussi s'en méfier jérôme
durain jean vigreux disais tout à
l'heure que finalement cette élection
c'est un peu une élection intermédiaire
notamment depuis le quinquennat et donc
vous en fait aussi un combat national
parce que là si la république en marche
fait un mauvais score à ces élections
nationalement on va dire en moyenne
nationale
eh bien vous direz vous voyez on est en
train de revenir évidemment il ya des
enjeux politiques par rapport à la
petite dommage mais c'est comme ça c'est
comme ça alors on va poser la question à
linverse pourquoi on nous fait une
circulaire castaner qui essayent qui est
d'ailleurs un tripatouillage à
l'ancienne c'est très très ancien monde
pour camoufler les résultats si c'est
précisément parce que cette élection
intermédiaire lé risque de venir marquer
une forme de défaite du nouveau monde
donc la politique elle s'invite à
l'occasion de ces élections municipales
ça a toujours été comme ça en revanche
les partis politiques qui portent des
idées à toutes les élections avec
constance et ils n'essayaient pas de
dissimuler leurs options réel derrière
des formules un peu creuse alors il ya
quand même alors il y a quand même dit
une forme de dissimulation c'est
qu'aujourd'hui
jean vigreux vous me direz si c'est le
cas depuis très longtemps mais
aujourd'hui les candidats là un peu tous
les parties évitent de mettre les logos
des partis sur les affiches sur les
documents de campagne il ya qu à
regarder le parc à dijon n'ai pas
l'impression qu'ils aient beaucoup de
locaux qui se battent sur les documents
de cambrai les uns et les autres là
c'est quelque chose de récent
effectivement dans cette
alors je sais pas si c'est la fin la
vème république mais un moment de la
vème république oui effectivement il ya
moins d'étiquettes qui sont qui sont
présentes
ça ça c'est clair ça se voit très bien
en revanche et même un autre phénomène
vous avez des gens qui se revendiquent
de certaines organisations politiques
qui s'y sont sur des listes d'autres
d'autres candidats il ya aussi un
patchwork est en train de se faire un
grand flou allant c'est pas énorme mais
ça ça commence aussi arrivé en revanche
c'est la place des organisations
politiques dans notre société
quelle est la place aujourd'hui les
parties quelle est la place aujourd'hui
de tous les organisateurs les
organisations quelles qu'elles soient et
femmes aux corps intermédiaires
intermédiaires et pourquoi ce comment
dirais-je faire cette logique mais
classique 1 de la 5ème parce que c'est
lié aussi à nos institutions entre le
pouvoir exécutif et les citoyens et
entre les deux il n'y aurait plus
d'intermédiaires à on supprime de fait
les camps ces intermédiaires les
référendum est la logique c'est moi
et de l'autre côté le peuple est le
rapport entre l'un et l'autre là c'est
ce que rené rémond avait montré sur la
dimension bonapartiste de la vème
république il ya peut-être d'autres
éléments me semble-t-il à regarder et
repenser le politique sébastien mirek
même du côté de la république en marche
on n'affiche pas forcément son étiquette
politique parce que depuis
demandez gilet jaune en plein mouvement
sur les retraites ne fait pas toujours
bon être proche des manuels macron
vis-à-vis de ses électeurs dont on
camoufle un petit peu est-ce que c'est
pas un peu un fou organisé vous êtes en
train de mettre en place à travers votre
progressisme municipal alors clairement
non
on a pas on n'a pas l'étiquette la
république omar chanteuse à titre
personnel et en tant que responsable du
parti au niveau départemental on n'a
absolument pas honte de d'afficher notre
appartenance à la république un bon
candidat aux municipales en côte d'or
affiche tous le logo la république en
marche alors répondait je ne réponds pas
tous comme ça parce que en fait on l'a
pas plusieurs modèles de soutien on a
des candidats qui sont investis qui sont
des candidats de la république aux
marches on a des têtes de listes qui
sont des soutiens avec un soutien public
en marche mais avec d'autres partenaires
locaux et logos mais après c'est aux
joueurs car la tête de liste de
l'affiché et de le mettre à titre
personnel nous on est on est on est très
très libre par rapport à ça et on n'a
pas l'étiquette honteux ça c'est un
point très fort je reviens quand même
sur un point tout à l'heure on parle de
nouveaux mondes d'anciens monde de
gauche de droite mais en même temps
maintenant j'ai bien ce fait là on a
effectivement ça je les aime bien
pourquoi parce que j'étais pas d'avant
et pourquoi je me suis engagé au moment
où emmanuel macron et vue est venu parce
que pour moi c'était le renouvellement
des visages et parce qu'on se retrouvait
pas dans cette société de droite de
gauche avec des extrêmes qui montait
aussi aucun moment il faut se retrouver
et on est dans un débat démocratique et
démocratique pardon et on défend nos
valeurs républicaines et le progressisme
municipal est une forme de raisonnement
et on le porte et on va continuer à
porter avec ces dispositifs l'un avec
d'autres il ya une plateforme qui est
complètement ouvert donc elles
accessibles à toutes les sensibilités
politiques et on est vraiment repart de
la base on part du citoyen et ça c'est
ce que nous avons fait dans le programme
présidentiel pour les municipales pour
les européennes et infra pour la suite
et l'idée cette soirée par 2-0 olive ans
je le sais je vais je laisse la parole
on part de zéro au niveau des élus au
niveau de la république en marche ou
quasiment
ce qu'on souhaite c'est lui multiplié
par cinq au niveau des conseillers
municipaux et ont fait
des alliances et on en a fait et on en
fera à gauche à droite jérôme durain je
vais vous laisser répondre à sébastien
direct mais c'est vrai que même chez
vous les socialistes les locaux sont
plus à la mode au moins depuis françois
hollande
non mais il dira que les étiquettes sont
partout présentes et que chacun
revendique la filiation à partie ce
serait faux et vous avez raison de
constater qu'à une forme de confusion
notamment depuis 2007 mais je pense
quand même qu'un débat démocratique ça
peut pas être tout se vaut tout est dans
tout et réciproquement que l'après
droite gauche le nouveau monde et permis
de faire baisser les extrêmes
ça c'est pas bien vu quand même et je
pense plutôt si vous ne comprenez pas je
vous le dis comme républicains comme
citoyen si vous ne comprenez pas que ce
qui se passe dans ce pays c'est les
élites les techno bercy contre le peuple
la colère et la verticalité assumé par
le président de la république
cette espèce de dépolitisation qui ne
dit pas la réalité de la politique est
conduite elle se voit les gilet jaune
les manifestations sur les retraites
c'est quand même un climat social où les
gens veulent savoir veulent un discours
de vérité et votre histoire
c'est une forme d'entourloupe le
progressisme municipal le ni droite ni
gauche le en même temps c'est une forme
d'imposture emmanuel macron il était là
pour réconcilier le pays
il ne l'a pas fait et en continuant à
masquer la réalité et à essayer de 2,2
dissiper de mettre sous le tapis les
étiquettes politiques pour faire une
politique des meilleurs des techno
d'ailleurs si bête ndiaye elle le dit
elle dit en gros il faut qu'on ait des
technocrates parce que sinon on fait des
erreurs mais les gens ils veulent des
politiques est de savoir où
oui vont à un trump aux états unis avec
laquelle je ne suis pas en accord
idée des choses à la société américaine
il dit qu'ils les défendent
donc il faut aussi être courageux sur
les options qu'on a est pas tout le
temps se camoufler derrière l'absence
d'étiquette et avec des circulaires qui
sont des circulaires alors on va venir à
la circulaire et jean vigreux j'ai une
question pour vous il ya une politique
municipale de droite ou de gauche dans
notre histoire récente
elle est vraiment marqué ou est ce que
finalement la politique municipale c'est
le bien commun notamment dans les
petites communes qu'on soit de droite ou
de gauche ça ne changerait pas grand
chose c'est ce que disent un certain
nombre de maires de petites communes
notamment à travers les associations des
maires ruraux
qui demandait une suppression de ce
fameux nuance âge politique dans les
petites communes on lui demandait en
dessous de 3500 et parle de ça ce n'est
pas de 9000 c'est ce qu'ils ont à ces
sites et c'était ce que l'association
des maires de france présidée par
monsieur baroin demandait des 3500 et
réclamait etc donc on est revenu à ça
avec la logique du conseil d'état on
viendra peut-être sur la circulaire la
mobilisation aussi des enseignants
chercheurs de sciences politiques ou de
la société française d'histoire
politique parce qu'il y avait des choses
me semble-t-il intéressante à voir sur
le temps long mais sur la question
précise la différence oui il ya deux ans
je ne sais pas le geste sur pattes
il peut y avoir des différences et puis
voir des différends sur est-ce que vous
externalisez les services publics
ou est-ce que vous gardez un service
public est-ce que vous externalisez
l'eau par exemple ou est-ce que l'eau et
municipaliser en fait je vous envoie en
régie etc vous avez plein de choses
comme ça est ce que les enjeux de la
politique culturelle de la politique
sportive
elle est ouverte à tous dans une logique
de démocratisation ou est ce qu on est
simplement dans une logique de sport
d'élite professionnelle etc
il y a des différends moi je vous aurais
l'on peut à dire j'aurais dit les
caméras de vidéosurveillance police
méchaal ggg chalet de développer mais
vous me demandez une question je réponds
à tous les éléments où il ya les enjeux
aussi de sécurité ou de tranquillité
publique
comment on le présente quelle est la
position du maire et quel est le rôle du
maire mais aussi il ya un rôle qu'est la
police nationale et donc il le maire n'a
pas tous les éléments de police non plus
donc on peut avoir des idées des
différences quand même quand on regarde
une politique menée outre ne serait-ce
que les taux d'imposition aussi il ya
des choses classiques se regardait sur
les mêmes avaient bien sûr est large
mais pas toujours sûr pas toujours pas
toujours sébastien direct du coup il
faut bien se positionner politiquement
même pour les élections municipales en
matière d'idées tout ne se vaut pas si
j'écoute jean vigreux
alors je suis toujours je reviens sur ce
point je reviens juste un point ce qui
était répondait aux besoins rapidement
parce que c'est un sujet je peux pas
laisser dire qu'on parle d' imposture
qu'on ne dit pas la vérité
le programme présidentiel a été fait
avec la grande marche avec l'ensemble
des citoyens qui ont voulu participer à
ce moment là
et donc ça s'est fait en construction
avec les citoyens sur le terrain
deuxième point la réponse a été fait
avec le grand débat national avec la
convention citoyenne sur le climat avec
on verra les conclusions les citoyens
sont en train de bosser il ya des points
extrêmement important si je reviens sur
la deuxième question pour honte pour la
république en marche c'est quoi les
priorités d'un maire en marche parce
qu'en fait c'est vraiment cette question
droite gauche en marge du mal à savoir
on alors avoué très clairement dans les
critères qui ont été ressortis des
projets et du progressisme et de la
charte d engagement c'est avoir une
transition écologique qui est juste
concise qui est concrète qui est tournée
vers les jeunes à son futur ça c'est un
point important le deuxième point c'est
la promesse de mouret d'accord toi data
recorder d'accord vivre au mieux tout le
monde est d'accord à metz de vivre mieux
oui mais sans on le fait signer aussi au
maire aux candidats qui sont investis
par rapport à la république en masse
alors ce matin les valeurs républicaines
c'est pour ça qu'il ya eu dix
engagements qui ont été sortis avec une
mission flash de la république en marche
aussi et puis en fait on change la
méthode et je crois que ça c'est la
chose la plus importante c'est qu'on
change de méthode
alors il faut l'accepter on peut
l'accepter on ne peut pas l'accepter
mais très clairement ça correspond aussi
à la population et je me considère pas
comme une et une élite
à titre personnel dans madame à mon
histoire familiale
l'histoire d'immigrés polonais qui est
venu en creusot à montceau-les-mines en
saône-et-loire
je me considère pas comme une élite non
ça je ne peux pas laisser le sais pas
vous mais j'ai envie de m'engager par
millions que c'est un goût dont il
s'agît représente le parti je représente
le parti au niveau de la côte d'or et
mon rôle aussi est de dire que on est à
l'écouté des citoyens et de tous les
citoyens
mais ses passes tes amis avec le mieux
vivre ensemble et l'écologie tout le
monde est d'accord mais je ne sais pas
si un candidat en marche
s'il ya une idéologie une étiquette
derrière si lille est pour la gratuité
des transports en commun les caméras de
vidéosurveillance l'armement de la
police municipale ça va être comment ça
va être à la tête du client
et est ce qu'elle est ce qu'il ya une
ligue où est ce que vous dites non
finalement chacun fera comme il entend
en fonction des réalités de sa commune
on a mis un socle programmatique c'est
un programme qu'on est dit est ce un
socle programmatique de projets qui
marchent qui marche avec des résultats
et vous verriez les résultats pour une
partie donc ça c'est important
j'en ai en tête c'est sur la
désertification qui m'intéresse beaucoup
à joigny de maisons des internes ça
c'est quelque chose que j'avais porté
quand j'étais responsable des étudiants
des internes maison jouanny des ehpad
solidaire extrêmement intéressant les
ehpad solidaire avec le groupe sos ou en
fait on va faire du participer de ça
alors on va pas des de les nommer de
ligne évidemment tout le programme de la
république en main jérôme durain vais
vous répondre mais il faut qu'on en
vienne à cette circulaire car le temps
passe la serpillière castaner
aujourd'hui à 3500 habitants il n'y aura
plus en dessous 3500 habitants il n'y
aura plus le nuance âge fait par les
préfets est ce que ça vous convient
finalement ce seuil de 3500 habitants
alors que le seuil des 9000 et bien
privé finalement les statistiques
nationales de la moitié de vote des
français c'est mieux que ça ne devait
être en échappé au pire et le
gouvernement a pris quand même une
prestation sévères de la part du conseil
d'état qui a dit votre truc c'est quand
même du bidouillage c'était du
bidouillage parce que à 9000 habitants
on avait quand même 97% des communautés
qui n'était plus identifié politiquement
plus de 50% des électeurs à 3500 on
revient à quelque chose qui est plus
acceptable
et puis avait surtout cette capacité
pour en marche en disant je soutiens
tels de voir l'ensemble des listes qui
était soutenu par en marche
tombé dans une catégorie nouvelle
nouvelle pour en marche
c'était grossier donc on est un point
d'arrivée qui est plus satisfaisant mais
qui ne résout pas les questions
politiques ont apposé twitter parce que
si j'ai bien compris ce qu'elle était un
maire en marche
un maire en marche est un un maire qui
est pour tout ce qui va bien contre tout
ce qui va mal qu'ils respectent les lois
de la république éthique ni bonjour à la
dame a cessé quand même c'est pas
possible pas exactement ça mais quand
même c'est on va voir partout y compris
ce que voulait dire globalement je pense
que c'est la place de la politique dans
ce pays y compris au niveau local et
avoir une étiquette politique
avoir une sensibilité ça n'empêche pas
de travailler ensemble moi je suis un
sénateur identifié politiquement je
travaille elle tourne et au sénat on
travaille ensemble
il est d'ailleurs rare moment que vous
n'acceptez pas que quand marché
finalement bouleversé la donne et
l'échiquier politique est ce que c'est
possible à ce que vous rêvez vous ne
restez pas rare que goûter sur le passé
vous les partis dits classiques dits
traditionnels que ce soit les
socialistes que ce soit les républicains
que ce soit le parti communiste
c'est monsieur mirek des dix nous
c'était avant jeu avant que j'arrive je
ne considère pas que du point de vue
démocratique
l'arrivée dans marche au plan national
soit une bonne nouvelle une armée de
députés godillots qui font pas de
terrain des gens qui suivent et qui
votent n'importe quoi on l'a vu sur le
congé décès d'un enfant il va longtemps
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est bien le
nouveau monde moi je pense qu'il faut de
la clarté politique c'est quoi les idées
sur lesquelles on fabrique du consensus
dans notre pays donc je ne pense pas que
ce soit un progrès et je ne dis pas pour
autant que le modèle partisans il est
formidable et j'étais moi même
d'ailleurs unanime au sein du psg t il
pour la rénovation pour le non cumul
pour la 6ème république pour ça change
mais pas comme ça que là ça change pas
en cash to jean vigreux le nuance âge il
était parfois subi par les maires des
petites communes comme quelque chose de
négatif parce qu'on les étiqueter
politiquement alors qu'il n'en avait pas
envie
est ce que est ce que là il n'y a pas
quelque chose de positif dans cette
nouvelle formule de la circulaire
castaner alors il ya cet aspect positif
effectivement puisque on a abandonné 1
de fait le seuil on a abandonné 7
ce choix que le préfet devait faire
aussi parce que ça dépend des du regard
mais ce qui a été dit tout à l'heure
effectivement un candidat peut vous
faire avoir plusieurs étiquettes lrm l
heure où l air au mps ou l autre chose
et terra donc comment le comment le
placer et n'oubliez pas qu'en 2014 sur
les 8700 et quelques communes entre 1000
et 9000 habitants
vous en aviez 8000 qui avait revendiqué
une étiquette c'est à dire il n'y a pas
simplement la logique de la taxinomie
comment le préfet va les nommer mais
c'est comment les gens aussi se
définissent et moi je crois qu'il faut
donner la parole aux élus et aux futurs
élus de dire pas qu'est-ce qu'ils
veulent pas d'étiquette ou étiquette
mais c'est aussi à la base et c'est ça
la logique de l'émission vraiment en
quelques secondes les accusations de
tripatouillage politique voulait réfuté
complètement ou est-ce que c'était une
façon de minimiser le possible mauvais
score possible
il n'est pas question de faire dit pas
disparaître les étiquettes politiques
ces demandes quand même deux circulaires
elle émanait pas d'art public en marche
mais en fait elle émanait des sénateurs
et les airs sur le projet de loi
engagement et proximité et aussi d'une
monde historique de l'association des
maires ruraux de forme et ça vous
dérange pas plus que ça
ça a été discuté ça a été modifié et
donc on a réadapté par rapport à ça et
donc d'ailleurs il va y avoir une union
du centre union de la gauche union de la
droite étaient rassemblés de s'accrocher
mais le conseil d'état a suivi les
politistes puisque c'était quand même
une anomalie depuis 45 en france on
pouvait faire une histoire du temps long
on pouvait prendre tout ça et là on ne
pouvait plus le faire merci merci à tous
les froides avoir accepté de débattre on
suivra évidemment ces élections
municipales et les résultats avec ses
fameuses étiquettes au dessus des
communes de plus de 3500 habitants merci
à vous de nous avoir suivis dans un
instant un point sur l'actualité
régionale avec marie joly et la partie
nationale de dimanche en politique avec
francis letellier qui reçoit elle deux
députés la socialiste valérie rabault et
le marcheur ans roland lescure bon
dimanche
[Musique]